- Good morning believe nation.
Today's message is...
- Keep going. Over to you, John Legend.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning,
♫ Espresso keep me going,
♫ I wake up every morning.
- The thing is every
successful person you know
has failed at what they love to do before.
I've been unsuccessful in my career.
You just didn't know about it
because I wasn't famous yet
and I was trying to be famous.
I was trying to get a
record deal for six years
and I kept getting turned down
and any successful person you know
even though is seems like
everything just happened for them
it usually was preceded
by a bunch of failure
or at least a significant amount
but the great ones aren't
the ones that don't fail.
They're the ones that
learn from their failure
and they keep going and they're persistent
and they're tenacious and for me,
I was trying to get a
record deal from '98 to 2004
and I got turned down by
every major record label
including the one I'm signed to now
and for me that means
that even when you hear no
you have to keep going
through all those nos
until you get to a yes.
- So what do you think?
- For me, usually if I start a project
it doesn't matter how
hard it is or it will be
I will always continue to finish it.
Like for when I just
started my YouTube channel
I did the ten day challenge
and so many things break down.
The software shut down on me a few times
but I still stayed up
late and then kept going,
finish my editing.
Yeah it was tough that ten days.
- Benita kept going. She kept going.
I think people give up too easily.
I think people quit too soon.
I look at my YouTube channels,
since we're talking YouTube.
I started it in 2008 and it wasn't until
it wasn't until 2014 that I
had my major breakthrough.
So what is that? Six years.
Six years.
Yeah 2014 is when I had
my first kind of big video
that took off.
Six years.
Would you keep at something for six years
and not see any major results
and just keep doing it?
I think people just expect instant results
and when they don't get it they quit
and try to move on to something else
and then just move on to something else
and never stick with anything.
It's the key to success.
I look at successful companies.
Look at Harley Davidson, I may
get the numbers a little off
but they started I think in 1903
and they made five bikes
that year, five motorcycles.
In 1904 they made another five motorcycles
and then the next year they
made like seven motorcycles
and then two years later they
finally opened up the factory
and they made 50 motorcycles.
Like how long would you be
willing to make five motorcycles
and five motorcycles
and five and then seven?
Most people think that's a
failure and they quit too soon.
And so I think with
any goal that you have,
in entrepreneurship or in life,
you have to keep going.
Its going to be way harder
than you thought it was,
it's why it's so important
that you have a deep passion for it
because you're going to quit.
If you're in it just
for some instant result,
instant money, instant
gratification, you're going to quit
because it's going to
get way way way too hard
but if you have the deep passion
for it and you keep going
the prize will be yours.
So the question of the day today is...
- What is the thing that you're working on
that you have been
working on for a long time
and you still go into?
- I love it.
- Finish it.
- Oh I cut you off. I like it.
You kept going.
Leave it in the comments below.
We will join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Cristina Archer.
Cristina thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really
really really appreciate it
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever...
But your one word is we'll see you soon.
- No, no much love and we'll
see you again tomorrow morning
for another...
- Shot of Espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning,
♫ Espresso keep me going.
- In today's world you can't sleep.
There's no days off,
there's no time to rest and just kick it
so you just keep going you know?
So even though the album just came out
like they got me in the studio tonight.
I was in the studio last
night until six a.m.
We got a full day of like interviews
and running around in New York
and then we got studio all night.
You just keep going.
And that's how you keep your chops up.
- There were times in
the last five, six years
that I was very tempted to just say,
"You know what? Forget it.
This is too difficult,
you're not going to come up
with the album that you need
and you're driving
yourself crazy with it."
And I was- and of course on top of that,
I was getting quite a
kicking from the press.
So at that point in my life
with so much going on emotionally
being kicked about by the media
and the press and the industry
almost wishing that my career was over
I was almost ready to give up.
But part of my motivation,
a very strong part of my
motivation to keep going
was that I always knew
how terrible it would look
to young gay kids that were
worried about coming out.
Not that they necessarily
see a great parallel
with someone who was
outed when they were 35
but I think it would be a horrible way
to leave my career, to
leave people thinking
that my sexuality took away my marking
because I just knew that wasn't true
and I felt a kind of
responsibility not only to myself
but to young gay people to say look
because I would feel absolutely sure
that my marker hadn't left me
so I felt it really important to say,
"Look it is not damaging
if you have ability,
it is not damaging to have
the confidence to come out
and that in certain parts of life
it really doesn't matter anymore,
in certain careers it really
doesn't matter anymore."
And I think just the success
of the record this time around
and I hope its continued success
will alleviate that perception you know?